this little guy is the geekom as6 Mini
PC and you guys can see it is Tiny now
geekom saw our videos on the M2 Mac Mini
and they reached out and said hey we
have a Mini PC that has a great price
tag a ton of features and performance
and we want you guys to check it out and
compare it to the M2 Mac Mini and
feature it on your channel so let's go
ahead and do that now one thing that
surprised me was the price tag the specs
and the amount of upgradability that
they packed in such a small package so
starting out with the external
Dimensions you guys can see that the
footprint is much smaller on the as6
compared to the Mac Mini now with that
said it is a little bit taller but
overall the size is smaller and on the
back their actual mounting points where
you can use their Vasa adapter that is
included in the Box to mount it to the
back of a monitor or mount it somewhere
else so it stays out of the way now I do
want to mention that you do have an
external power brick so the power supply
is external compared to internal on the
Mac Mini now as far as ports this is
where it gets a little bit crazy because
on the M2 Mac Mini here we have no ports
on the front you have to spend at least
two grand for the Mac Studio in order to
get that whereas the as6 has your
headphone and microphone port on the
front you have a full-on thunderbolt
Port right here as well that can be
connected to displays and we have two
super speed USBS along with that power
button now if we take a look at the back
that is quite a bit of ports here now on
the M2 Mac Mini we have two fiber
gigabit per second USBS we have that
HDMI and then we have two Thunderbolt
ports right here we have your ethernet
port and we have one single HDMI now
this HDMI is not HDMI 2.1 you have to
spend at least 1300 whereas with the as6
we actually have two hdmis and those can
support 4K 120 so it's HDMI 2.1 now the
Mac Mini can support two displays and
that caps out the M2 Chip with the AMD
processor that's in here and the
graphics we can support a ton of
displays so we have those two hdmis we
also have a display port and that
Thunderbolt Port that's also on the back
you don't have to just use it for
storage or devices that's also a display
output we also have three super speed
regular USBS and we have that ethernet
port now on the M2 Mac Mini it comes
with one gigabit Ethernet unless you
spend another one hundred dollars
whereas the as6 well it meets it
somewhere in the middle because it's
including the price and it's 2.5 gig
ethernet you can't get 10 gigabit but it
is upgraded from the factory now
internally this is where it gets
interesting the as6 actually comes with
not 16 gigs but 32 gigs of RAM to get a
comparable Mac Mini you're gonna have to
spend fourteen hundred dollars to bring
you up to one terabyte and it caps at 24
gigs of unified memory so that is
Unified and that is 1400 bucks how much
does this ASX cost well right now you
can get it for 749
and there's a lot of upgradability which
I will show you guys now the mini of
course has the M2 Chip that is unbinned
whereas the as6 has the AMD R9 6900 HX
processor along with AMD Radeon 680m
graphics now on the bottom of the ASX we
have four Phillips screws that are built
into these rubber feet of course the M2
Mac Mini is no longer upgradable of
course with PCS even something as small
as this as6 we can actually unscrew the
feet and we are going to lift up this
cover and that just opened up
our little mini PC now as you guys see
right here we have
um this little ribbon cable that is
connecting both parts here and on the
bottom side we have part of the
motherboard and then up top here you
guys could see we have this little
addition that houses some of our ports
now what is interesting is that right up
here we actually have a slot for a two
and a half millimeter SSD or hard drive
so yes you can still use a traditional
drive like that so that is nice to be
able to have cheap storage that you can
add in but apart from that even though
this has a one terabyte m.2 SSD you can
actually add another one because it has
dual slots so you guys can see under
this ribbon cable right here I'll be
really careful with it we have that
additional slot right there along with a
little pad and a little piece of
heatsink underneath that's going to cool
it down even in a small four Factor like
this but that is actually not all
because if you look right here we
actually have slots for our Ram so this
comes with 32 gigs in this configuration
for that 750 price tag by the way use
the link down in the description you
might even be able to get an additional
coupon on that and we'll have our link
as well so check it out you can actually
remove this so if you want more RAM you
can actually upgrade that as well which
is really cool now what you guys do not
see here is a heat sink and that is
because it is built into the underside
of this tiny motherboard and the way
that it works is that it pulls in air
from one side and pushes it out to the
other side now you might think that with
the PC this small ended being
um you know x86 based processor it would
be quite loud well I was actually really
surprised by how quiet it is of course
with the M2 Mac Mini it also has a fan
built in and because of the Apple
silicon design it does stay pretty much
silent most of the time now comparing
the built-in SSD speeds as far as write
speeds the Mac minis uh one terabyte
option actually beats out the as6 but as
far as their read speeds the as6 beats
out the Mac Mini but that is the
included one for that price tag these
slots though are actually PCI Express
four so you can put in a faster SSD now
Apple they will charge you 800 bucks to
go from the base to storage up to two
terabytes which is the maximum that you
can get internally and that's one of the
nice things about having a PC based one
is you get a lot of upgradability now
now this thing also has a Wi-Fi 6E chip
for that price tag just like the Mac
Mini so that is a great thing now the
ASX comes with Windows 11 Pro
pre-installed so that is a great thing
you get the upgraded operating system of
course the Mac Mini comes with Mac OS
and there are pros and cons to both
systems for example I have many friends
that work off of mini PCS because they
need Windows for their professional
workflows and I also have friends
including us that use Final Cut Pro for
video editing so we need Mac OS but what
about performance well the Mt Mac Mini
comes with the M2 Chip which is very
powerful and it is unbinned in the Mac
Mini which helps it out and uh this
thing has the AMD processor that is
capped at 35 Watts as far as geekbench 6
which has been updated and definitely
shows the full performance of the M2
Chip in single core score both are over
2000 but the Mac Mini does Beat It Out
And as far as multi-core score both are
over 9000 we have about 9 500 compared
to 9800 so the Mac Mini does beat it out
but with the eight performance cores and
then 16 threads that does help it out in
multi-core performance as far as
graphics performance I ran geekbench
sixes longer Graphics test and the Mac
Mini using metal scores 44 000 with that
unbanned Graphics chip that is in there
whereas the as6 it gets about 27 000
using Vulcan so the as6 with that 6900
HX and the 68m graphics perform wise
Compares more so to the M1 Mac Mini
maybe slightly better in the CPU
category and so the Mac Mini overall is
going to get you better performance of
course we have that price difference and
upgradability and that is where geekom
is showing off this thing I also want to
mention if you're buying one of these
for the upgrade ability for the ports
for the storage things like that and you
don't care about performance that much
they actually have the AMD ryzen 7
version and that maximizes the value
that you get so I see these devices as
two devices for different purposes
they're both very tiny and as far as the
Mac Mini is giving you a great value for
the money it's not the only thing that
could be low priced and small if you're
focusing on a small form factor you guys
don't know your thoughts down in the
comments section below if you guys want
to check this out go ahead and use our
Link in the description below to get
more info more pricing coupon details
things like that click that Circle above
to subscribe check out one of those
videos right over there this has been
Max and I'll see you in the next one